notre cher ami nous savons françois
bonjour aux gens s'ils disent non et à
moi me dit pas bonjour un parent de noix
que c'est bien je t'avais prévu ah oui
c'est parce que je suis un peu mince ac
a plus de club ou dame je suis merci
sans façon casimir nous vous n'auriez
pas vu le facteur j'ai rendez vous ici
avec lui paul à la pêche à la crevette
la mèche à la promesse mais je ne vais
pas les laisser sécher mes amis les
crevettes
vous êtes là monsieur doucement oui je
suis là mon cher et 1000 et vous avez
failli me faire attendre vous savez que
je n'ai pas ça du tout oh je vous
demande de m'excuser monsieur du stop et
c'est mon chef qui m'a fait faire un
quart d'heure supplémentaire bon allez
n'en parlons plus médine - annoncé rémi
l'a1
je croyais qu'on allait à la pêche non
carnaval roman est surprenant et très
même ridicule mais c'est vous monsieur
du snob tu n'es tu pas dans l'auto on ne
va pas à la pêche aux crevettes ont
rhabillé comme ça mais oui moi à votre
place j'aurais mis en smoking en plus de
globules gare à l'eau merci casimir jeu
préféré manger ma casquette
ils ont raison monsieur 19 vous êtes
beaucoup trop élégant pour les cravates
vous allez abîmer votre joli costume le
facteur lui ça le facteur est
parfaitement équipé et regarder sa pêche
aux crevettes qu'elle remonte un peu de
gloubiboulga françois non merci nous
immerger jamais entre les stocks
schultz l'abri ou avez vous mis votre
filet mais voyons mon cher emile vous
savez bien que je ne garde mon fils est
sur la tête que la nuit pour dormir
enfin que mais je veux garder leur
ondulations mais je ne vous parle pas de
votre filet pour les cheveux monsieur du
stop
mémé du filet pour pour aller à la pêche
à la crevette comme le mien mais je
comptais les attraper à la sportive à la
mer oh là là monsieur du stop
soyons un peu sérieux d'accord oui je
crois que vous avez besoin d'une petite
répétition un goûter gg tout ce qu'il
vous faut
ici mais tout d'abord a tenu à l'équipe
a les clés en soit il faut faire quelque
chose qu'on ne peut pas les laisser chez
les gros becs rien pourquoi devant kazim
et mais enfin il nous dit hugues atchy
rude et toutes les autres enfin toutes
mes amies et crever ah bon ce sont des
amis je comprends mon pour caser mais
oui chaque fois que je vais à la plage
trempé mais mignon petit pied dans l'eau
elles viennent autour et le château
gentiment ne parle pas papa doc le
débogage
oh non merci casimir même pour te faire
plaisir merci beaucoup écouté riz merci
dû continuer sans arrêt à nous proposer
de tombi boulga naine nous tes meilleurs
amis du risque de nous faire fuir arrête
tiens tiens
[Musique]
vous avez perdu quelque chose malin
casimir
ben voyons et 1000 mhz apprend comment
repérer les crevettes et bien vous
manach après pas une sole au nom de
l'amitié comme porte les crevettes
je ne laisserai pas monsieur du snob et
mm dans leur assiette et après mon cher
emile comment devrais-je me prendre
après vous tiendrez votre filet comme
ceci monsieur du snob oui main gauche en
bas main droite en est surtout bien
d'aplomb sont vos jambes c'est comme ça
cet enfant tu es moins cher et 1000 pour
un joueur de golf de ma classe je sais
juste que je le vois pas très bien ce
que le golf vient faire dans la pêche à
la crevette
mais voyons la technique est
pratiquement la même oui au golf vous
tenez votre club
de la même façon et de la ruine et
frapper la balle ronde mais n'allez
surtout pas faire ça moi vous allez
faire peur aux crevettes et vous
éclabousser ah ben on va continuer votre
démonstration à un ami je compte
oui oui je vous en prie donc vous êtes
la finale la mer tout autour de vous oui
évidemment évidemment un bousquet bruit
vous vous avancez sur le sable
sablonneux jolie avec doussain oui ça
oui
calmement oui oui oui vous y allez je
vous suis je suis je suis là voilà au
bout d'un moment vous stoppez bon vous
relevez votre filet et vous ramassez le
produit de vos efforts que vous mettez
alors dans votre petit panier et puis
ainsi de suite arrêter tout simplement
chez nous permettez que je le fasse tout
seul
pour sûr vous avez besoin
d'entraînement alors alors alors les
bras les bras dès 4h et nous voilà
décontractée par tête du sne ont des
contraintes et les jambes souple voilà
voilà voilà comme ça chez emi c'est ça
c'est ça revient et on avance doucement
le nez au vent
l'oeil aux vans important à la pêche aux
crevettes va très très mal à l'aise
comme ça arrive et bonbons souviendrai
m'enfin bon ben je crois que nous
pouvons y aller c'est l'heure de la
marée allemand shereni louis la marée
haute ou la marée basse la marée basse
ou ailleurs en fait demain c'est quand
on va à la mer se retire que nous
retrouvons les crevettes comme ça dans
le sable donc dans les trous d'eau très
bien géré ce dimanche à lille
alors en avant allons-y aller à la pêche
aux crevettes de matane est le jeu va
bien signalé
et à la pêche aux petits 80 tonnes la
drogue à la province voilà où oui oui à
la monsieur riches non vous êtes déjà de
retour - certes ça n'a pas marché
oh que nous à nous on parlait pas appel
à lège mis un pied dans l'eau qu'un
énorme crabe est venu me passer le gros
orteil tenez regardez moi ça c'est pas
bien beau oui c'est bon d'être en croque
monsieur oui c'est un vieux crabes très
sympathique mais c'est curieux parce que
moi il ne m'a jamais pensé je laime bien
moi quand monsieur parce que c'est le
seul tram qui adore le gloubiboulga à
leur facteur la pêche a été bonne hélas
non mademoiselle julie naud d'étape
détritus flotte sur l'eau là la mère est
pollué commence à l'année et poli
hélas et toutes les crevettes ont filé
vous savez je rentre chez moi bien déçu
à je vous suis mon cher et me pardonnez
moi mes chers amis mais mon gros totori
me fait terriblement mal je rentre chez
moi
et bien moi je vais remplir mon bol de
gloubiboulga comment ce n'est que déjà
tout danger à tout alors tombé de
gloubiboulga non non non je n'ai rien
mangé du tout j'ai tout jeté à la mer et
qui s'est passé exactement ce que vous
aviez prédit
c'est à dire quand les cowboys se sont
toutes sauvées pour ne pas être obligé
de le manger alors la mer polluée
c'était toi avec ton gloubiboulga si
cette intelligence fait que vas tu faire
avec le filet du facteur sont proches je
ne peux pas laisser perdre d'aussi bons
gloubiboulga jeu mais vite aller le
récupérer avant que son bourg mans deux
groupes monsieur et tout manger
[Musique]
quelle chance j'ai eu de vous rencontrer
jamais je ne serai arrivé tout seul
jusqu'ici avec cette valise jamais porté
de balises aussi lourde
heureusement vous êtes en effet m'a
servi je vois pas qui dans l'île
pourrait porter un objet aussi lourd
est ce que vous avez entendu la même
chose que moi un facteur conclure
monsieur du snop se croient que le
personnage mais le plus fort de l'île
ça c'est la meilleure de la journée avec
elle est bien bonne le pauvre la même
pas de muscles en écoute est restée là
vous allez voir je ne bouge pas bonjour
jury salue casimir
alors monsieur du snob on a des petits
problèmes
oui je vous aide à casimir te fera le
plus grand plaisir
en gardant en ironie pour toi que tu me
rendre service mais bien sûr bavard au
fond du jardin cg suis non vous il est à
toi que dis tu as question idiote
réponse si dia ho le coût très faible ce
n'est pas l'heure des plaisanteries
l'espoir porté sept bannis juste bien
julie que je mette cette manie j'avais
bien derrière le kiosque près de la
porte d'accord excusez moi monsieur du
snob
alors je crois mais c'est du snop que
vous avez oublié quelqu'un des mirettes
un quasi virus
le vrai qu'ils sont quatre à je vous
observez ce coup du sort on est pas un
homme très musclé pas vrai comment vous
osez mettre en doute ma puissante
musculature de soyons sérieux monsieur
d'us normes vos biceps sont plus que des
petits pois des petits pois qui pourrait
bien vous envoyer mes deux points sur le
nez c'est un défi parfaitement monsieur
je suis à votre disposition
moussu lentilles marque
bravo à thomas se voudra pas maintenant
c'est du snob facteurs ne vous discutez
pas aller serrez vous la main je suis
désolé ma chérie alea jacta est
les dés sont jetés et bien nous en avons
pas mais c'est pas possible c'est
françois qui n'est pas la casim effet
quelque chose à nous non je trouve ça
très bien
ça va se passer pas à pas à monsieur
duchesneau chaos et pourquoi moi parce
quand je suis pour le facteur ça suffit
si vous vous battez bien je vous avertis
je vous interdit de remettre les pieds
au jardin c'est impossible
il m'a lancé un défi à ce n'est pas une
raison
trouver autre chose j'ai une idée moi il
me reste des sacs de sable de mon voyage
en bateau
alors je vais les mettre dans deux
caisses celui qui soulèvera la caisse la
plus lourde sera le vainqueur
bravo casimir ça c'est une bonne idée il
me semble en effet que nous pourrons
accepter ce genre de compétition à sa
poursuivre celui qui soulèvera le plus
de sacs de sable sera le marqueur et
casimir toi et moi ne seront les
arbitres et vous allez voir nous allons
gagner facteurs enfin voyons que des
murs il faut être impartial un coin
partial qu'est-ce que ça aide c'est bien
ou pas bien partial impartiale
ça signifie être juste ne pas chercher à
avantager l'un ou l'autre des
concurrents tu as compris d'accord je
sors à un arbitre impartial
allez vas t'occuper des sacs de sable
moi je m'occupe des deux caisses et vous
vous mettez ont tenu un attention le
perdant valérin les allées du jardin
[Musique]
oh
où
louis
alors de 3,3 sade et trois sacs
alors pour la première épreuve
les trois sacs de sable vous êtes prêts
bon alors allez-y 2 3 très bien après
c'était plus ou moins à nos choix et je
vous ai préparé deux verres de creney
julie pas bien sûr casimir tu ajoutes un
sac de sable dans chaque est oui
serait ce serait quand même dommage que
ce soit monsieur du jeune homme qui
gagne personne ne regarde bien non voilà
attention pour l'épreuve des cathos sac
dépêchez-vous de trois fusées ou hausse
était de plus en plus durs mois avec
l'entraînement ça m'a paru bien plus
léger mais j'ai toujours soin et vise à
définir
[Musique]
attention et prendre des cinq ça je
regrette je ne peux pas facteur vous
êtes le vainqueur peut dire que si non
non non non ne bougeait pas joli nom
c'est cette caisse m'a paru bien légère
georges
je vais voir dedans et ben c'est bien ce
que je pensais il ne reste plus qu'un
sac dedans
casimir m'a aidé je suis pas le
vainqueur
je suis éliminé ont écouté mon bon ami
le reconnaissons que nous avons été
ridicules tous les deux et puis décide
donc il n'y a ni vainqueur ni vaincu
or avec plaisir mon brave cheyrou la
main aux lentilles et bien je préfère
vous voir comme ça tient pour fêter
votre réconciliation je vous offre du
gâteau au coeur
le voilà attendait alors s'il n'y a pas
de perdants qui va balayer les allées du
jardin
[Musique]